imagina que estamos dirigiendo algún
tipo de compañía y esta compañía produce
un cierto tipo de aparatos un cierto
tipo de dispositivos déjenme anotarlo
los cuales por buena suerte toda la
gente los utilizan son unos dispositivos
de moda y estos dispositivos tienen dos
principales costos de producción el
primer costo de producción importante
que tienen es la mano de obra déjame
escribirlo con este color la mano de
obra y por otra parte el segundo costo
más grande que tienen es el material del
que están hechos estos dispositivos
están hechos
supongamos de acero entonces estos son
los dos costos más importantes que
tienes y voy a suponer que el costo por
mano de obra es de 20 pesos por hora lo
voy a escribir aquí es de 20 pesos por
hora de cada uno de tus trabajadores
este es el primer costo que tengo y
luego voy a suponer que el costo del
acero es
se me ocurren de dos mil pesos de dos
mil pesos pero bueno este no es programa
este es por tonelada así que teniendo
estos dos has contratado a unos ciertos
analistas que trabajando un poco con
esta información han encontrado un
modelo para los ingresos que tú puedes
obtener vendiendo estos dispositivos y
este modelo es una función de las horas
de mano de obra que trabajan los
empleados y de las toneladas de acero
para hacer estos dispositivos así que
imagina que el modelo de ingresos que
elaboraron es una función r le voy a
poner r a esta función y bueno digamos
que es una función primero de las horas
demandas de obra y también vamos a
fijarnos en las toneladas de acero así
que voy a poner a para las toneladas de
acero y bueno encontraron que el modelo
de esta función es igual a 100
h elevado a la potencia dos tercios ok
que multiplica a ha elevado a la
potencia un té así muy bien observa que
si pones una cierta cantidad de horas de
mano de obra y una cierta cantidad de
toneladas de acero entonces esta función
r h te va a dar la cantidad de dinero
que obtienes o que esperas ganar al
vender tus dispositivos y por supuesto
lo que vas a querer hacer es ganar tanto
como puedas
pero en realidad tienes un presupuesto
para cuánto puedes gastar en mano de
obra y en acero así que vamos a notarlo
imagina que tienes un presupuesto para
gastar de 20 mil pesos en tu compañía
están dispuestos a gastar 20 mil pesos y
bueno claro quieren hacer tanto dinero
como puedan de acuerdo con este modelo
ahora esto es exactamente el tipo de
ejercicio que está hecho para la técnica
de los multiplicadores de lagrange
estamos tratando de optimizar algún tipo
de función y tenemos una restricción
esta restricción de aquí no está escrita
como una fórmula pero muy fácilmente
podemos escribirla como una fórmula ya
que que conforma nuestro presupuesto
bueno va a ser la cantidad de horas de
mano de obra multiplicada por 20
entonces 20 por la cantidad de horas de
mano de obra ya esto le sumamos la
cantidad de toneladas de acero por 2 mil
2000 por la cantidad de toneladas de
acero que te gastes y bueno esta
restricción va a ser igual al
presupuesto que tú tienes así que va a
ser igual a 20.000
ahora podría ser también menor está
restricción pero intuitivamente y en la
realidad va a ser el caso que tengas a
fin de optimizar tus ingresos deberían
de aprovechar al máximo cada peso que
tengan disponibles y verdaderamente
alcanzar esta restricción ahora observan
20h más 2000 a igual a 20 mil a esta de
aquí le voy a poner un nombre y voy a
decir que esta es la función g de h
h así que esta va a ser mi función g y
esto nos va a servir porque si
recordamos un poco lo que vimos en los
últimos vídeos la manera en la que
visualizamos algo como esto es pensarlo
como el conjunto de todas las entradas
posibles así que qué te parece si lo
visualizamos para que todo sea más claro
voy a dibujar por aquí un eje de las
toneladas de acero que tengo y por aquí
lo voy a tomar a mi eje h a mi eje de la
cantidad de horas de la mano de obra así
que voy a ponerle el nombre este va a
ser mi eje y este va a ser mi eje h en
este eje tengo la cantidad de horas de
mano de obra am y en el otro eje tengo
la cantidad de toneladas de acero ahora
bien esta restricción de aquí lo único
que nos está dando es una recta una
recta que se ve más o menos así es una
función lineal y por otra parte esta
función de ingresos va a ser un conjunto
de curvas no sé se me ocurre que tal vez
los ingresos de diez mil pesos se vean
más o menos así
los ingresos de 100 mil pesos se vean
más o menos así es decir tenemos una
familia de curvas pero lo que queremos
encontrar es qué valor apenas está
tocando las rectas la restricción es
decir una curva que sea tangente en un
solo punto a esta recta es la
restricción a un solo punto y esto es
porque la recta tangente a la curva es
aquella donde si suben un poco el valor
un poco al menos entonces no sé inter
secaría con esta recta no habrá más
valores de hsm que satisfagan la
restricción y la manera de pensar en
encontrar esta tangencia es considerando
el vector perpendicular a la recta
tangente a la curva en este punto que
afortunadamente representa al gradiente
se ve más o menos así es más déjame
quitar esto para que no nos estorben
vamos a quitar esta gráfica que tengo
aquí porque me voy a centrar en
este vector que tengo aquí este vector
es el gradiente de esta función r así
que lo voy a escribir es el gradiente de
r de nuestra función de ingreso y para
hacer tangente a la recta de restricción
vamos a tener otro vector que se va a
ver más o menos así va a ser otro vector
que va a ser el gradiente de g
y se ve más o menos así este de aquí es
mi gradiente de g
y para nuestra suerte ambos apuntan en
la misma dirección es decir es
proporcional al vector gradiente de r y
la manera típica de escribir esto es que
el gradiente de la función r
déjame ponerlo con su respectivo color
el gradiente de la función r este va a
ser igual a una cierta constante que voy
a llamar lambda que multiplica el
gradiente deje al gradiente de g y esta
lambda que es una constante de
proporcionalidad tiene un nombre muy
particular y muy importante a esta
lambda se le conoce con el nombre déjame
ponerlo por aquí a esta lambda se le
conoce con el nombre de multiplicador de
lagrange multiplicador de lagrange muy
bien así que continuemos y comencemos a
trabajar en esto que tengo aquí así que
primero vamos a calcular el gradiente de
r
el gradiente de r se va a ver como en la
primera componente tengo la parcial de r
con respecto a la primera variable con
respecto a la primera variable que es h
en la segunda componente tengo a la
parcial de r con respecto a la segunda
componente que es a con respecto aa así
que vamos a calcular cuánto es esto esto
me va a quedar como bueno la derivada de
r con respecto a h eso es lo mismo que
ok que va a multiplicar a bajamos el
exponente estamos derivando con respecto
a h así que hay que aplicar la regla de
las potencias a h me quedarían por dos
tercios ok que multiplica a h elevado a
la dos tercios menos uno lo cual es
menos un tercio menos uno
tercio ok que multiplica a ha elevado a
la un tercio ok
esta es nuestra primera componente y acá
abajo voy a hacer la derivada de r con
respecto a up así que me va a quedar 100
que multiplica y bueno voy a poner el
exponente de am recuerda baja y me queda
un tercio ok que multiplican a h elevado
a las dos tercios en este caso h la2
tercio solamente se ve como una
constante que multiplicamos a amd
elevado a la potencia un tercio menos
uno un tercio menos uno es menos
éste era el gradiente de r ahora vamos a
hacer por acá el gradiente de g
así que si pienso en el gradiente de g
bueno pues éste va a ser igual y déjeme
poner las dos componentes va a ser a la
derivada parcial de gm con respecto a la
primera variable que es h y la derivada
parcial de g con respecto a la segunda
variable que es a ok entonces me va a
quedar fuera esto es más fácil porque
tenemos una función lineal y si tenemos
una función lineal diago la parcial de g
con respecto a h entonces de esta
ecuación que tengo aquí solamente me voy
a fijar en la parte que tiene h y la
derivada de 20 h es simplemente
ok esto por una parte ahora que me fijo
en la derivada de g con respecto a a
bueno me fijo en la parte que tiene a
todos los demás es constante es una
función lineal y derivó 2000 a su
derivada con respecto a am es
simplemente 2000 2000 ok entonces si me
fijo en el gradiente de r igual a lambda
veces el gradiente de g
entonces obtengo dos ecuaciones las dos
ecuaciones que obtengo las voy a poner
aquí son las siguientes déjame bajar un
poco en la pantalla para escribirlas
bien entonces la primera me va a quedar
de la siguiente manera la primera es
todo esto que tengo aquí
cien por dos tercios lo voy a escribir
como doscientos tercios doscientos
tercios que multiplican a h elevado a la
menos un tercio bueno eso es exactamente
lo mismo que poner h elevado a la
potencia un tercio recuerda cuando
tienes un signo negativo podemos bajar a
la variable y cambiarle el signo a la
potencia y que multiplica a ha elevado a
la un tercio
ok y esto va a ser igual a quien a
lambda veces la primera componente del
gradiente de gm que es 20 entonces esto
va a ser igual a 20 veces quien lambda
que lo voy a poner con su respectivo
color 20 veces lambda muy bien esto por
una parte porque también tengo una
segunda ecuación que es esta de aquí 100
por un tercio me quedan 100 tercios
tercios de h elevado a las dos tercios
elevado a las dos tercios esto a su vez
dividido entre ha elevado a los dos
tercios aquí tengo un signo negativo
entonces lo paso para abajo y esto va a
ser igual y de nuevo va a ser igual a la
segunda componente de nuestro gradiente
de gm que es 2000 2000 pero hay que
multiplicarlo por lambda hay que
multiplicarlo por lambda así que lo voy
a poner con su respectivo color 2000
lambda y todo esto sale porque estos dos
vectores tienen que ser proporcionales y
bueno creo que justo aquí es un buen
punto para detenernos y en el siguiente
vídeo continuaremos con estas dos
ecuaciones hasta poder obtener los
valores de amp y de h correspondientes
trabajaremos en los detalles y
aterrizaremos en una solución